what i want to do in this video is get
ourselves a little bit more comfortable
with the idea of strings and also see
the power of strings and all the things
we can do to them
or do with them so i'm going to do up
here is i'm going to write a little
simple program that'll essentially just
define a bunch of strings for me and
then i'm going to use the python
interpreter to play with those strings
and see what we can do to them so let me
define a string let's call the string a
and a is
let's call it my first test string my
first test
my first test
string right over there and as we know a
string is just a big sequence of
characters right over here and you could
recognize them because they'll either be
in single or double quotation marks and
just to make clear that it doesn't have
to be double let me define b
let me define b to be
another
another test
string
that
i have defined
and just to clarify on how you can
define strings you can actually put you
can actually put quotations within the
quotation marks as long as it's clear
where the string begins and ends so
let's say you have something like this
so let's say you say this
is sal's
this is sal's string this is sal string
so in this example
this apostrophe is okay it's a single
quotation but it's okay because the the
interpreter will know that look it's the
string starts with a double quote so i
have to have to look for another double
quote for it to end so it's not going to
say oh it ends at the single quote it
says i need to end with a double quote
so it knows that this whole thing is a
string and it also knows that this
apostrophe is just a character one thing
i couldn't have done i can't do let's
try to define string d here so let's say
let me define it this way so i couldn't
have done this this is
sal's
string
this doesn't make any sense because here
we're opening with a with a single
quotation then it'll close right when we
get to the next quotation and so all of
this is just going to be some text that
the interpreter is going to try to view
some type of program and it's going to
break on that so if you want this to
work you can't have it like that you can
you could do something like
like
you could do something like sals no you
can't do that so my favorite and there
are ways to do that and we're not going
to go into escape characters and all of
that right now but my favorite
word
is and actually i don't know what my
favorite word is i'm kind of putting
myself on the spot but let's say my
favorite word is
asparagus s i can't even spell it as
asparagus so my favorite word is
asparagus
what is yours what is yours so once
again this is legitimate because i start
my string with a single quotation mark
so it says look let's not end the string
until we get to another single quotation
mark so it's not like it will confuse
the interpreter when it sees this first
double quotation because it knows that
the string started with a single
quotation
let me show you some other examples of
strings and these will be interesting to
deal with and they don't always have to
be named label so this is let me call
this my math string let's just call this
a math string
and let's call this let's say this is 3
plus 4
3 plus 4 times
times two so that's a matte string it's
literally just a string of characters it
doesn't it's it's the interpreter won't
evaluate it literally just views it as a
string of characters so i think this is
a pretty this is a pretty good let me do
let me do one other kind of pseudo math
string or let me do another expression
let me call this an expression string
so these are that's just the name of the
variable and let me say
my expression string is
is
let's say it's a
plus
a plus and then i'm going to have a
that's kind of a string inside of that
string
plus
plus b
a tiger plus tiger right over there so
this is just so everything in between
the double quotation marks the
interpreter was just going to view as a
bunch of characters but there there are
interesting things that we might be able
to do with this eventually so that's
enough strings for me to define so let
me save this file right now and let me
run it
let me run it and what this does now in
this environment all of these strings
are defined and i can verify that i can
say a my first test string b another
test string that i have defined c this
is sal's test string
d
my favorite word is aspara asparaus i
couldn't even spell asparagus properly
maybe we'll have to fix that asparagus
what is yours that needs the g asparagus
what is yours and then we have this good
thing this isn't a spelling video we can
look at what math string looks like
matte string it's literally that string
of characters and then we have the
expression string
the expression string literally just
that string of characters now let's
start to play around with some of these
strings and see what we can do with them
so a couple of things we could see hey
how long is a string and there we could
use the built-in python function len
which is short for length so the len of
a
the len of a
says hey there's 20 characters in a
let's count it let's verify it one two
spaces of character three four five six
seven eight nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
18 19 20. yes 20 characters
what's the len
of math string
math string len for len length for short
math string is five characters let's
count them one two three four five
characters makes a lot of sense so we
could do it for any of them i encourage
you to try this out yourself really
experiment become comfortable with this
now the next thing i want to do is how
to show you how to concatenate two
strings sounds like a very fancy word
but it really just means connect them
together so for example i would say
let's let's define let's create a new
string let's call it a
a
with b
a with b and i'll define it as a plus b
so something i'm doing something very
interesting here you're used to using
the addition operator with numbers but
i'm about to add two strings i'm about
to add two strings let's see what this
looks like
so let's look what a with b looks like a
with b is just a variable
now what happened i had a which is my
first test string and i had b which is
another test string that i have defined
when i took a plus b it took a my first
test string and it added b to the end of
it it concatenated b to a concatenate is
just a fancy word for put them together
another test string that i have defined
so it merged a i guess you could view it
as it put b at the end of a and you
could go the other way you could call it
b
with
a let's say that is
b plus a
and then let's look what that looks like
b with a
now it's the other way around a is added
to the end of b so you can do very very
fascinating strings you know if we did
if we did math string plus expression
string math i'm not going to set it to
any variable i'll just see what i get if
i evaluate that math string
plus expression string
expression string then i essentially got
these two strings added together and so
what this string got put at the end of
this string and you see it right there
it's this kind of bizarre looking string
but it is a string everything between
these characters everything between the
double quotation is just viewed as a
character these are just
characters
now there's many many many many other
things we can do with strings i'm not
going to introduce you to all of them
but strings come with a bunch of
functions and if you have an integrated
development environment it'll often tell
you what types of functions you could
use for example you might want to split
maybe you want a list of all of the
words in a string so maybe i have i'm
writing some type of program and i want
to take this string that's in b and i
want to put each of these words as a
separate element in a list so what i can
do is i could say b dot and i'll call
one of the methods of b and we'll do
much more on methods and object oriented
programming and all of that but when you
we can view b it's a string object and
it has its own methods that can operate
on itself
for now you can just say look if i want
to split b
into
into its component words i can call the
the split method i could call the split
method and i can say and i can say what
do i want to split it on so when i say
split i mean separate the string into a
bunch of things and put them into list
and split split the string wherever i
see a space so let's see what we return
when we get that so notice it took this
string another testing that i've defined
it separated the string wherever there's
a space and took what's on what's on
either side of space and put it as an
element in a list could be useful if
you're doing some type of text
processing but i want to show you it
doesn't have to be split just where you
have just where you have a space you
could say b dot
b dot split and you could split whenever
there's a t
so you can split on the t and this will
give you some bizarre looking thing so
notice every time there was a t it split
the string there and it put what was
ever on each side of those t's it put
them into a separate element in this
list over here so very fascinating
things i mean you can do things like
finding finding where a character is in
a string so let's say you want to call
i don't know let's say you want to call
let's try the math string
the math string and i want to find in
the math string so it's one of its
methods i want to find
that asterisk in another word i have
trouble saying so find the asterisks
tell me which character if any has an
asterisk in it
it tells us the third character does
let's verify it so this is the first
character sorry this is the zeroth
character that's the beginning that's
the convention in most computer programs
zeroth character first character second
character third character is an asterisk
if you wanted to find the three you and
i really encourage you to experiment
with this
find the three
it's the zeroth character there
now there's there's other stuff you can
replace characters you can say look
let's take let's take i don't know let's
take
let's take c and let's replace
let's replace all of and i and you can
either look look it up in a book or just
do a web search you can normally find
all of the libraries for python strings
or if you have an ide integrated
development environment it'll suggest
things that you can do to strings and
how you do it but let's say we want to
replace in string c all of the i's
we want to replace all of the i's with
o's
let's see what we get
so there you go it was this is sal's
favorite this is sal string when you
replace it with os and i want to be
clear it didn't change string c it
created a copy of c with the o with the
eyes replaced by os so then it became
dos os sal's strong it sounds like a
i don't know like a nordic language of
some kind and just to be clear c did not
change but if i took if i said c equals
c dot replace
and replace the i's with
os
with os then c has changed to das ass
sals strong now the last thing i want to
do is show you kind of a very magical
function at least from my point of view
and that's the eval function and it it
exists in interpreted languages like
python and it also exists in javascript
so what's really cool is
is it can evaluate a string it can view
a string you can treat it as a string
for a while and you can construct it so
you could you could for example have a
computer program that writes another
computer program inside a string and
then evaluates that and then evaluates
that computer program so that should get
you philosophically thinking a little
bit so for example if i just say math
string
if i just say math string it's just a
string of characters but if i say eval
math string
if i say eval math string it'll actually
the interpreter will actually evaluate
what's inside of this so it'll actually
treat it as an expression and so i get
11. so it takes math string and says
okay now let me treat that as like a
program so it's 3 plus 4 times 2. order
of operations does the 4 times 2 first
so that's 8 3 plus 8 is 11. and you can
do even cooler things you could do eval
let's think about this math string
and let's add to matt's string let's add
to matt's string a character
the character one and let's see what it
gets us
gets this 87 what did it do well what it
did is mat string is this stuff but if
you add a 1 to it
it would look like that the 2 would
become a 21 we're concatenating a 1 to
the end of it so it became 4 times 21
which is 84 plus 3 which is 87 and you
can do other things we can evaluate this
expression string right over here that's
why i set it up like that eval
expression string
eval expression string really fun to
play with i could do this all day eval
expression string remember expression
string is just a string but when we
evaluate it you might want to pause and
think what you're going to get so let's
evaluate it
i got all this craziness where did that
come from well in the string these were
just characters a and b but when i
evaluated in our current context a and b
are variables and they represent strings
so when you evaluate this thing it's
going to say okay a is a string that's
my first test string concatenate or put
the space at the end of it so my first
test string and then i have a space
and then put b at the end of that so
another test string that i have defined
then put
then put a space tiger and then you have
a space tiger so i'm going to leave you
there
as you can imagine strings are super
super duper powerful concepts for doing
a bunch of applications and i encourage
and i haven't exhausted anywhere near
all the functions or things you can do
with them so i encourage you to
experiment